this morning our series eye on earth
explores how climate change is
threatening a symbol of Christmas this
is the season for santa's famous
reindeer but at the North Pole the herds
are plummeting in size over the past 20
years wild reindeer and caribou
populations have declined by more than
two million mark Phillips takes us to
what's called Santa's hometown to find
out why these animals are struggling to
survive after more than a million years
on earth good morning from northern
Finland about 300 miles north of the
Arctic Circle
reindeer country that's them in the
distance over there but this isn't about
Santa Claus hohoho kinds of reindeer
this reindeer story is no laughing
matter it's more than a thousand miles
from up here in the High Arctic of
Finland to the North Pole as the
reindeer flies but that hasn't stopped
the Finns from naming Rovaniemi the
capital of Lapland Santa's hometown
where Rudolph's cousins provide sleigh
rides albeit on the ground and where you
know who welcomes children of all ages
but all is not what it seems in this
winter wonderland
so Rudolph here real name year Moe is a
healthy young reindeer but hundreds of
thousands of others are in real trouble
to find the real reindeer and the real
trouble you've got to go about 250 miles
north of santa's village and then drive
a snowmobile another 30 or so miles
across rough open
in temperatures approaching zero but
winter even up here isn't what it used
to be our guide is untag up you so from
the ancient Sami people who have been
herding reindeers since the dawn of time
and the climate here in Lapland he says
is changing if it's warm weather yeah
then it's no gonna be it melts melts and
next days choruses knees yeah does it
happen more often now where you have
rain or warm weather and then the snow
melts does that happen more in the last
few years that has been yet and this is
the result reindeer are dying a big
die-off was discovered on the Arctic
islands of Svalbard last summer and the
huge wild herds of caribou same animal
which roam across Alaska and northern
Canada have been reduced by half
according to a recent government report
so they dig down through the snow and
ante the reindeer herder knows why the
reindeer feed even through the winter on
lichen a mossy plant they dig down
through the snow to get at except when
all that thawing and refreezing means
they can't and when the snow turns to
ice what happens to the rain do we have
to feed them because they can't no we
have to give them extra food up here in
the land of the Northern Lights it's a
constant battle dante lives in a village
of just ten houses five families no
power no running water the most remote
village in Finland he says which is
saying something
and everyday he travels up to sixty
miles each way through the few hours of
dim winter light to find the herd and
check its okay how many reindeer do you
hurt how many do you have I have some
radiance but it's same thing if I ask
you how much you have money on the back
to you the reindeer are your money in
the bank my Rand is my whole whatever
your worth
my whole worth they run about 5,000
animals and right now it's reindeer
roundup time ante and his wonder dog
Benna gather the scattered herd and
drive themselves to where they can bring
them feed and where a few are sold off
to the reindeer meat market it's how
they make their living it's a gorgeous
if frigid dance of man animal and
machine it's very hard work up yeah I
see that is hard work
some days why don't you leave and go
work in the city or so this is my life
these reindeer in Finland are the lucky
ones they have the Sami herders to look
after them for tens of thousands of
other ones elsewhere though the human
influence hasn't been so kind yeah I
don't think I'd want to move from there
to the city either I want to move here
go do that job sounds like it's
dangerous it's pretty disturbing numbers
yeah it is
little pictures but a serious problem
yeah influence I like Benny that little
dog yeah those